let me begin by updating you on the
latest information from the government's
Cobra file on the first slide here we
can see the latest information on
infections results from the ons
infection survey published this morning
estimate that the number of people who
tested positive of coronavirus in
England fell from 150 mm between the
27th of April and the 10th of May to
33,000 between the 25th of May and the
7th of June this is encouraging progress
and suggests that around 1 in 1700
people in the community had coronavirus
during the latest period of the survey
sage has also confirmed today that their
estimate of the our rate for the UK is
unchanged on last week at Northpoint 7-2
not 0.9 we want to keep the r8 number
below 1 and our of course is the average
number of additional people infected by
each infected person the second slide
shows the confirmed cases with a test 6
million 430 4713 tests for coronavirus
have now been carried out or posted out
in the UK this includes one hundred and
ninety three thousand two hundred and
fifty three tests carry out carried out
or posted out yesterday two hundred
ninety two thousand nine hundred and
fifty people have tested positive an
increase of 1541 cases since yesterday
the graph shows a steadily falling
number of identified cases on a
seven-day rolling average despite the
increase in testing the third slide
shows the latest data from hospitals 535
people were admitted to hospital with
coronavirus in England Wales and
Northern Ireland on the 9th of June down
from 720 to a week earlier and down from
a peak of 3432 on the 1st of April 392
Corona
as patients are currently in mechanical
ventilation beds in the UK down from 571
a week ago and down from a peak of 3301
on the 12th of April the fourth slide
shows what is happening in hospitals
across the country there are now five
thousand six hundred and seven people in
hospital with coronavirus in the UK down
20 percent from seven thousand and
thirty six a week ago and down from a
peak of twenty thousand six hundred and
ninety seven on the 12th of April as the
graphs show while there is some
variation most nations and regions in
the UK are broadly following a similar
pattern the fifth slide shows the daily
figures for those who sadly lost their
lives after testing positive for
coronavirus across all settings the
total number of deaths now stands at 41
thousand four hundred and eighty-one
that's an increase of 202 fatalities
since yesterday where measured by a
seven-day rolling average the daily
number of deaths currently stands at 174
down from a peak of 943 on the 14th of
April although the number of deaths is
now firmly down our deepest sympathies
go out to all those who have lost loved
ones transport is instrumental to our
recovery to connect people with jobs to
help level up Britain and even to make
us a healthier and more active nation
but as people start to travel transport
also presents one of our biggest
challenges how we protect passengers
prevent the spread of virus even as we
become more mobile transport use may be
the first occasion since the onset of
kovat that we've shared confined spaces
with others so it's critical for it
critical that we all take a vigilant and
cautious approach over the next few
weeks I'm just going to say this if you
can work from home you should continue
to do so if you cannot work from home
you should try to avoid public transport
if you must use public transport you
should travel a quieter times of day and
if you are an employer you should do
everything in your power to prevent
staff from traveling unless it's
absolutely vital and please do allow
staff to travel a quieter times now from
Monday it becomes mandatory in England
to wear a face covering on public
transport that includes trains buses
trams ferries and planes a face covering
does not mean a surgical mask face
coverings can be made at home and you
can find guidance to do so on Gavi UK as
we move to recovery it's more important
than ever to protect each other
preventing those showing no symptoms
from infecting others I know there's
huge public support for compulsory face
coverings they show respect for our
fellow travelers but for clarity
transport operators will be able to
refuse permission to travel where
someone isn't using a face covering and
this weekend I'm taking powers through
the Public Health Act
leading to fines for non-compliance to
will take a gentle approach to
enforcement during the first couple of
days and help will be at hand in
addition to the British Transport Police
the staff from Network Rail from TfL
Transport for London and transport
operators in the coming weeks will also
deploy journey makers to assist and
remind commuters of the need to wear
face coverings plus the safer transport
campaign will provide plenty of
reminders bus stops and rail stations
and on social media
remembering your face covering should be
the same as picking up your phone your
wallet or your purse
whenever you're leaving the house please
read the guidance ensure you have a face
covering and protect your fellow
commuters this crisis has tested our
nation yet through adversity comes
possibility a greener transport future
within our grasp for example through the
two billion pounds investment in the
cycling and walking program the
challenge though is to make Transport
currently our biggest emitter of
greenhouse gases part of the solution
not of the problem if you take the
aviation sector for example which has
had an impossible few months yet despite
these obvious challenges there's a real
determination within the industry to
have a greener restart so we're bringing
together leaders from aviation
environmental groups and government to
form the jet zero Council this group
will be charged with making net zero
emissions possible for future flights
our goal within a generation will be to
demonstrate flight across the Atlantic
without harming the environment and
today we're backing a company called for
losses who are building a plant for
aviation biofuels in Lincolnshire I'm
also excited about it Cambridge
Cambridge University and Witsel labs
projects to accelerate tender
technologies for zero carbon flight the
shared experience of fighting
coronaviruses changed us in many
different ways
it's although it's forced us apart it's
also brought us together although it's
tested us it's also shown us and our
very best and although it's made us
reflect on the past it's focused us on
those plans for the future but now as we
become more mobile we must not forget
this insidious virus is still a threat
their own that not only means avoiding
public transport if you can it also
means from Monday wearing a face
covering on public transport avoiding
gatherings of more than six people
including to protest I understand that
people want to show the passion for
issues that they care deeply about and
we must never be complacent about
stamping out racism and discrimination
in this country but please for the sake
of your health and that of your friends
and families don't attend mass
gatherings